first of all two billion dollars is that
is that a break even some they need to
reach well maybe that's the number uh
that that the creator of all of this
James Cameron said that the film would
have to hit in order to break even I've
had this romance with the ocean my
entire life the way of water connects
all things
you're on Pandora
[Music]
by now I'm sure you've heard about
Avatar too against many people's
pessimistic expectations Avatar 2 has
crushed it at the box office having
crossed one billion dollars within just
12 days and by the time you're watching
this it may very well be at two or even
three billion dollars three billion
would make it the new box office King
but then again do you really expect
anything different from James Cameron
what may be surprising however is that
Avatar likely won't be making all that
much profit even if it does reach these
record-breaking numbers in fact
according to Cameron himself Avatar 2
will have to be the third or fourth
highest grossing film in history just to
break even this means that Avatar must
cross 2 to 2.2 billion dollars simply to
not lose money now we all know that
Avatar 2 cost a bunch of money to make
but there's no way it cost 2 billion
dollars to make right well that's
correct while Cameron hasn't revealed
exact production numbers current
estimates put the film at 250 million
dollars this means that for some reason
Avatar needs to pull in at eight times
its budget at the box office to break
even even if we use higher estimates for
the budget like 460 million dollars
Avatar would need to pull in over five
times its budget at the box office this
makes no sense when you consider that
films with similar budgets have far
lower break evens take James Bond
Specter for example specter's production
budget was 300 million dollars but it
only needed 650 million at the box
office to break even even Avengers end
game which cost 400 million to make only
needed to earn 1.1 to 1.2 billion in
other words despite having a similar
budget to end game if not lower Avatar 2
needs to earn twice as much at the box
office to show a profit now to be fair
Cameron did admit that Avatar 2 doesn't
make sense from a studio financing
perspective and that it's the quote
worst business case in movie history but
that still leaves the question where's
all the other money going so here's the
baffling economics of Avatar 2 and why
Avatar needs to earn 1.5 to 1.75 billion
dollars more than its budget just to
break even
starting off we have the most obvious
Factor eating into Avatar's profit
margins which is splitting revenues with
theaters now having to split revenues
isn't unique to Avatar but there are two
characteristics that are unique that
make splitting revenues especially
costly here's the thing most theater
deals are set up to make the average
movie as profitable as possible for both
parties this means that Studios get a
larger percentage during the opening
weekend and first few weeks while
theaters get a larger percentage after
week three or four this makes sense
because most movies have a massive Cliff
after the first week or two as a result
theaters are able to sustain at lower
splits during the initial phases of a
movie because showings are packed and
people are buying a bunch of concessions
but during the later phases of a movie
theaters need a higher split to given
that attendance is much lower and a
fewer percentage tend to buy concessions
this works out great for Studios as well
given that they get a larger split while
a given movie is pulling in the bulk of
its Revenue however as time passes
they're willing to settle for a lower
split to maximize the time that a movie
stays in theaters in terms of numbers
Studios generally start with 55 to 60 of
the revenue and they drop down to 40 to
45 percent sometimes this ends up being
as low as even 30 percent while this is
an ingenious design it's not all that
beneficial for Avatar given that it
doesn't perform like the average big
budget film you see it Avatar is not the
type of film to have massive opening
weekends like Marvel and it's much more
of a slow burn this is why we saw so
many articles early on suggesting that
Avatar was getting destroyed at the box
office when in reality that wasn't the
case and this becomes abundantly clear
when we compare the staying power of end
game and the original Avatar and the
game started off with multiple nine
figure days while Avatar barely had it
20 million days when we look further
down the line however this Dynamic is
flipped on its head by day 51 Avatar was
still having eight figure days while end
game was barely achieving seven figures
while this is great news for Avatar's
longevity and it's not all that great
when it comes to theater splits while
end game likely only enjoyed splits at
55 or 50 for their first week or two
given that that's where all the revenue
was the average take in the US was
likely closer to 55 percent meanwhile
Avatar is much more likely to be weighed
down by lower splits in later phases and
your average take is likely closer to 50
or maybe even slightly lower this may
not sound like a big deal but when we're
talking about box office numbers of two
to three billion dollars we're talking
about 100 to 150 million dollars less
into your earnings despite the same box
office numbers for perspective that
margin itself would be enough to direct
the entirety of Batman Begins so due to
the mechanics of theater splits Avatar 2
has to earn a lot more to keep the same
amount
foreign
theater splits are already a headache
for Avatar 2. that's just the first of
Disney's problems with the movie another
major hurdle that Disney has to deal
with is International Revenue splits
here's the thing Western Products
usually attract the richest and most
well-off people in a given country
countries are well aware of this and
that they want a share of the revenue
this is why products like the iPhone are
hit with a 20 tariff and imported cars
are hit with a nasty 100 tariff in India
Cameron doesn't get any freebies in this
realm and he's gonna have to Pony up in
entertainment tax of anywhere between
two and fifty percent probably closer to
50 in India I've been picking on India
but they're by no means the only ones
with such policies the UK for example
has a tax of 20 now technically it is
the End customer who has to pay for
these taxes but it would be stupid for
Studios to not subsidize these taxes
whatsoever otherwise they'll end up like
apple with four percent market share in
the second and most popular country in
the world Disney obviously doesn't want
to do this because unlike something like
Top Gun the vast majority of avatars fan
base is actually International with the
original avatar for example only a
quarter of its box office actually came
from America while over 2 billion came
from other countries to maintain this
International success however Avatar 2
tickets have to be somewhat reasonably
priced even after massive taxes of 40 or
50 percent and the only way to
accomplish this is to sacrifice margins
significantly usually this reduces
profit margins to somewhere between 20
and 40 percent the UK for example is on
average 30 percent while China and
Russia are 25 and 38 respectively now
Avatar is not the average movie so it'll
likely be able to boast a larger
International premium than the average
movie but even if we call it 40 that's a
big drop from the domestic 50 percent
again a 10 difference is worth 200 to
300 million dollars on an avatar scale
enough money to direct a whole nother
Avatar if we apply these numbers to
cameras Break Even of 2 billion dollars
we can get a rough estimate of just how
much the studio will actually earn as
I'm making this video the global
domestic split for Avatar 2 is roughly
70 30. so we'll just roll with that this
means that when Avatar 2 reaches 2
billion dollars the global draw would be
roughly 1.4 billion dollars while the
domestic raw would be roughly 600
million dollars using our box office
splits of 40 and 50 we get a global keep
of 560 million and a domestic keep of
300 million this adds up to a total
retained revenue of 860 million dollars
and keep in mind that's with our Avatar
premium tickets estimation the real
number may actually be closer to 700 to
800 million so that explains 1.1 to 1.2
billion dollars worth of the box office
but that still leaves us us with a 600
million dollar gap between 860 million
and the budget of 250 million so what
happened there
well the first thing that we should
point out is that it's highly unlikely
that Cameron actually stuck to the
initial budget of 250 million the
initial Avatar itself cost 237 million
to make and if you've seen the new
Avatar you know that there's no way that
this film will only cost an extra 13
million if that's actually the case
Cameron actually pulled off a miracle
but more realistically the film probably
cost 460 million to make like the higher
estimate suggested with an estimated box
office retention of 860 million dollars
this only leaves us with 400 million and
there's still plenty of expenses like
marketing the original Avatar is
estimated to have spent 150 million
dollars on marketing and that was when
Avatar was a completely unproven concept
given that Avatar has since become the
world's highest grossing film and that
Disney has acquired a franchise and that
they need an insane box office number to
break even I suspect that Disney will be
more than willing to outspend the last
Avatar in terms of marketing the the
marketing budget is likely 200 or 250
million dollars but what color 200
million to be conservative which leaves
us with another 200 million about 100
million of this will go to random
miscellaneous expenses like interest
rates Studios generally fund a lot of
their production in using debt and that
this was likely especially expensive on
Avatar 2 given that it's been in
production forever meaning that there's
plenty of time for interest to stack on
not to mention the reason to rate hikes
another place in which Disney will lose
some money is currency fluctuations and
exchange fees you can't just convert
billions of dollars worth of foreign
currencies to US dollars for free Disney
will also have to spend some money on
miscellaneous distribution expenses and
sales agent fees it takes a lot of time
and effort to actually get your film
into the hands of thousands of theaters
around the world in dozens of formats
and languages putting aside these
miscellaneous expenses we still have a
hundred million dollars and that this
will likely be paid out to large
stakeholders in the project this usually
include its major actors for example
Cameron offered 10 of Avatar's profits
to Matt Damon if he joined the team
Avatar didn't end up starring anyone
like Leonardo DiCaprio Brad Pitt or of
course Matt Damon but Sam Worthington
does get five percent of the profits and
the other major characters like Zoe
Saldana may have similar agreements it
should be noted though that these
figures are based on profits not to
gross box office numbers but there may
very well be stakeholders that are paid
off the top line one of the most notable
stakeholders is of course Jimbo himself
he said that Avatar would have depend 2
billion for their Studio to make money
not for himself to make money in the
given that Cameron himself is worth 700
million dollars he's clearly no stranger
to making lucrative deals with Studios
foreign
may be baffling to cure that 250 million
movie needs 2 billion to break even it
actually makes a lot more sense when we
take a closer look and account for
things like the movie going over budget
theater splits Global splits marketing
distribution fees economic stuff and the
key stakeholders but at the end of the
day Cameron didn't make this film to
make money if that was truly his main
goal he wouldn't have waited 13 years to
release another movie for him this is
much more of a passion project and about
bringing his vision to reality with that
being said though we can't just
completely ignore the economics because
that's what keeps lights on and allows
Cameron to do all this crazy stuff
fortunately for Avatar though it doesn't
look like it'll have much trouble
breaking even and who knows it might
even become the new world's highest
grossing movie especially if it has
anywhere near as much sticking power as
the original and this should go without
saying it but if you haven't seen this
movie yet you absolutely shouldn't but
that's just what I think are you a fan
of Avatar comment that down below also
drop a like if this video gave you more
context regarding box office revenues
and profits and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as future video ideas and to consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys a next one
thank you